[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes au théâtre
alexandre dumas à saint germain en laye
voici le sommaire du champ du théâtre ou
encore de la danse le théâtre de saint
germain les nous présente sa
programmation 2022 nous avons pu
assister aux répétitions d'une nouvelle
création théâtrale
l'artiste cambrésienne geneviève
monjarret expose ses oeuvres à la
galerie des passions à andrésy jusqu'au
27 février vous pourrez découvrir ses
collages et enfin la micro folie aux
mureaux organise une soirée concert 100%
reggae ce vendredi 18 février plusieurs
groupes de ce genre musical seront à
l'honneur je me trouve au théâtre
alexandre dumas saint germain en laye la
saison et 2022 au théâtre est lancé
gilbert desveaux bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le directeur du théâtre alors
comment se passe cette nouvelle saison
nylander elles se passent plutôt bien vu
les circonstances vu les conditions
sanitaires qu'on connaît on ne retrouve
pas tout à fait le niveau d'avant la
pandémie mais mais c'est vrai que le
redémarrage se fait se fait plutôt bien
et on sent que le public est très
heureux de revenir dans cette très belle
salle du théâtre alexandre dumas et où
globalement on arrive à être quasiment
plein chaque représentation c'est super
c'est une bonne chose pour vous puisque
vous avez subi
moi je suis arrivé un an et demi à la
direction du théâtre et c'est vrai que
j'arrivais dans un théâtre fermé un
théâtre qui était voilà en repos alors
on a fait beaucoup de résidences on a on
a programmé beaucoup de compagnies voilà
avec benoît dissaux le directeur
artistique pour que les compagnies
puissent continuer à travailler on a
monté des ateliers hors les murs et puis
et puis la saison est repartie alors
c'est une saison un peu particulière
parce qu'elle est composée de beaucoup
de reports beaucoup de spectacle avait
été programmée l'année d'avant voir
l'année d'avant mais les voilà dans
l'ensemble dans l'ensemble on est
heureux dans l'ensemble on est heureux
ici s'il 28 février on peut
effectivement envie le masque en salon
sera encore plus heureux alors justement
attirer la programmation la à venir ben
le théâtre alexandre dumas c'est un lieu
qui se doit d'être ouvert à tous le
public donc notre notre mission c'est
une mission de service public c'est
d'être connecté au territoire sur notre
aire de jeu donc donc c'est toujours une
programmation très pluridisciplinaire
qui mélange d esthétique très diverses
avec l'objectif de toucher tous les
publics les jeunes les moins jeunes les
les érudits les novices et ça c'est une
mission qu'on aime beaucoup alors vous
vous donner quelques exemples quelques
grands rendez-vous des tas fars oui oui
il y en a plusieurs il y en a plusieurs
il en reste puisque on est on est juste
en février et on est ouvert jusqu'à fin
on est actif jusqu'à la fin du mois de
mai je citerai fracas ce qui est une
très belle adaptation théâtrale du roman
de théophile gautier par jean christophe
humbert qui est un acteur qu'on a pu
connaître parce qu'il a il a fait ses
débuts dans l'équipe de kaamelott c'est
un garçon très talentueux et c'est un
grand spectacle un spectacle pour moi
tout public à partir de 10 11 ans très
spectaculaire très voilà une espèce
d'hommage au théâtre dans toute sa
dimension avec des effets spéciaux avec
voilà et puis
ici c'est un lieu et le plateau s'y
prête merveilleusement c'est un lieu qui
est traditionnellement dédié à la danse
et on est très heureux d'accueillir
après marie claude pietragalla qui vient
avec son solo la femme qui dans ce cas
un très beau spectacle et puis on la
retrouvera très certainement l'année
prochaine ici et puis le si je ne me
trompe pas le dernier le dernier
spectacle de la saison c'est une manie
avec son concert voodoo cello où elle
réinterprète avec une un hors caisse de
violoncelle des grands succès des erp en
connaît dustin de radiohead etc et voilà
ça devrait être une très très belle
clôture de saison très justement parmi
tous ces spectacles le mariage forcé
elle sera présentée jeudi 17 février à
20h45 c'est une création du théâtre et
nous nous avons assisté aux répétitions
regarder
[Musique]
ils prennent possession du plateau du
théâtre de saint germain en laye les
cinq danseurs de la compagnie de danse
l'éventail répète chaque geste pour
s'approprier l'espace ils seront
accompagnés sur la scène par cinq
comédiens et 10 musiciens alors
qu'istres ensemble ils jouent le mariage
forcé une comédie ballet de molière et
lui
ce canard elle a 53 ans a décidé
d'épouser dorimène qu'on a probablement
17 donc on peut s'attendre ce que de rue
mais ne soit pas contente et vinci elle
est ravie elle est ravie parce qu'elles
pensent que redémarrer les riches que
comme ça l'air sûre elle ne sera plus
soumise à la tutelle de son père et
qu'elle pourra faire ce qu'elle voudra
comme elle voudra ce n'est pas vraiment
l'idée que sganarelle faisait du mariage
tel est pris qui croyait prendre celui
qui voulait forcer la jeune fille à un
mariage se retrouve forcée d'épouser la
jeune fille
créé au xviie siècle le mariage forcé
est la première vraie collaboration
entre lully molière et beauchamp dans
cette version 2022 de nombreuses
adaptations des défaites là nous avons
proposé un décor des costumes qui n'ont
aucun rapport avec le xviie siècle en
tant que tel mais dont on espère qu'au
contraire ils ont reflété précisément
l'espèce de joie de fantaisie dire
réalité de poésie de loufoquerie qui est
tout le sel du mariage forcé le metteur
en scène et la chorégraphe de la comédie
ballet travaillent étroitement ensemble
pour mettre en lien les parties
théâtrale et les parties dansées un
travail complexe je trouve ça vraiment
très difficile parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de contraintes d'espacé justement
avec un orchestre vivant c'est à la fois
passionnant et en même temps basse est
beaucoup plus risqué tirer le fil entre
ses 400 ans pour à la fois ne pas
dénaturer l'esprit le sens de ce qu'il
ya de ce qu'ont voulu faire molière
lullier ébauchant le maître à danser à
l'époque et que ça parle à des gens
maintenant de partager ça
voilà c'est une gageur la première du
mariage forcé aura lieu ce jeudi 17
février à 20h45 sur la scène du théâtre
alexandre dumas
alors gilbert desveaux viens de voir le
reportage c'était important pour vous
d'imaginer une création autour de
l'année molière alors l'année molière ça
a été c'était une décision c'était une
décision même du maire de la ville qui
voulait qu'on célèbre qui compte qu'on
célèbre molière molière est quand même
très attaché sa vie est très attaché à
la ville de saint-germain-en-laye parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a toujours voilà on
oublie que ce château de saint germain
en laye a été le siège du but du
gouvernement un lieu un lieu où elle est
louis xiv et il ay là il a vécu
longtemps très longtemps et bien
évidemment quand il était là et bien là
cour suivait et les plaisirs était là et
molière faisait partie de l'équipe il a
créé plusieurs pièces ici et voilà
c'était une façon de lui rendre hommage
donc année molière qui qui qui rayonne
dans toute la ville et dans tous les
équipements de la ville
donc nous on a quatre spectacles
molières cette année et puis voilà avec
l'idée de croiser à la fois du théâtre
la comédie ballet des formes un peu plus
différentes alternatives mais
mais faire une création accompagner une
très belle équipe comme celle des malins
plaisirs c'était important pour nous et
d'ailleurs on l'a on a le souhait dans
les années à venir chaque année
d'accompagner au moins une équipe voire
deux ans création parce qu'on est on est
plutôt un théâtre de diffusion mais
c'est important pour nous de voilà
d'être au service des artistes et qu' il
puisse utiliser ce plateau pour créer
leur spectacle n'est justement autre que
le mariage forcé est ce que d'autres
créations sont à sont à prévoir oui
alors ça ne sera pas créée ici mais
c'est son année de création il ya le
tartuffe que met en scène yves beaunesne
qui est créée cette année et qu'on
accueille dans sa tournée et puis alors
un peu plus tôt dans la saison c'est
déjà passé il ya eu le george dandin de
michel fau qui est un spectacle avait
été créé avant le qu'ovide arrêté et
c'est un spectacle des bouffes du nord
extraordinaire une autre comédie ballet
remarquable et puis on terminera la
saison avec une forme un peu plus
alternative qui est une version pour un
seul comédien du don juan qui sera joué
salle tati et qui est là aussi un projet
qu'on destine particulièrement aux
jeunes voilà collégiens lycéens et il y
aura quatre représentations salle tati
dont des représentations vraiment
réservé aux scolaires ok va très bien
c'est noté les rendez vous sont pris
merci à vous tue le verbe ego d'avoir
été notre invité on part à andrésy
maintenant l'artiste geneviève monjarret
expose ses oeuvres à la galerie des
patients jusqu'au 27 février elle y
présente collage encre et pastels
regarder la création de geneviève
mangeard et artistes andrésienne ses
douze collage fantaisistes et singulier
présentée dans la galerie des passions
d'andré dit
vous avez là une porte de prison qui
s'ouvre avec une licorne qui exprime le
rêve dans les nuages et les tableaux
sont vides à l'intérieur mais bon et
puis l'heure le ticket n'est trop beau
c'est une sorte d'allégorie d' comme ça
de symbolique
[Musique]
un découpage fruit d'un travail amorcé
en 2020 quelques assemblage plus tard
l'exposition est née geneviève a dû
toutefois y ajouter une pincée de touche
personnelle d'où le nom de l'exposition
collage encre et pastels dans cette
thématique là de l'écolage oui
effectivement parfois il ya une
complémentarité de avec pastel avec
parfois un peu de peinture d'acrylique
de ça dépend en fait la fin justifie les
moyens
comme thème récurrent les oiseaux
j'habite dans un endroit où j'ai la
chance d'être au dessus de la scène et
de voir le matin comme le soir volé les
oiseaux alors je ne sais pas si ça eu
une influence peut-être sais pas mais
surtout l'artiste s'est laissé porter
par son inspiration
moi ya pas de sens
obligé où
chacun y voit ce qu'il veut et ça s'il a
la liberté de pouvoir
vivre regarder quelque chose comme on a
envie de regarder ça c'est très
important dans la galerie se trouve
aussi une partie d'anciennes création de
l'artiste andrésienne l'exposition est
en accès libre du mercredi au dimanche
de 10 heures à 19 heures et jusqu'au 27
février
dans les yvelines une autre exposition à
prévoir à partir du 5 mars à
l'hippodrome de rambouillet venez
découvrir des espèces disparues les
dinosaures une exposition avec de
nombreuses reproductions notamment des
tricératops ou encore les brachiosaures
la ville des mureaux propose une soirée
100% reggae ce vendredi le 18 février
plusieurs groupes seront un talonneur et
différentes soirées live seront
organisés maintenant trois à quatre fois
par an
[Musique]
c'est la ville en lien avec la villette
qui a fait l'acquisition d'une micro
folie vous avez un musée numérique vous
avez un fab lab est ce qu'on appelle le
café unis kropoly donc au sein de cette
micro folie nous aurons donc les
concerts à la médiathèque ou du micro
folie d'ailleurs
le 18 février qu'on commençait une
nouvelle pour nous donc avec trois
groupes comme je vous disais de reggae
donc c'est tous les styles et rica
tendance reggae on a un banc compagnie
et à partir de 20 heures donc à 19h45
c'est l'ouverture des portes pour le
public donc la passe vaccinale oblige de
toute façon et la ligue on s'installe on
à la première partie il ya en plus une
pause hier un petit entracte part parce
qu'il ya le café micropolis justement et
sai on a vraiment bull et qu'en même
temps là tous les musiciens le public
ait un échange qui pourra se faire sur
ce ton buvette et après on continue et
on va dire entre 23h et de trois enfants
ce temps du concert
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
prochaine session le 6 mai sera variété
ses critiques 31 un big bang qui fait
entendu parler de ça dont certaines
émissions comme taratata il toucha les
riches affichant derrière c'est des gens
qui jouent énormément de répertoire
assez large pour tous les styles donc
c'est très facile comme ça
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine dans un autre lieu
culturel yves binois bonne soirée sur
tv5 118
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]